right now a big question for ding what
to do next how to stop magnus from
copying his moves it's the most
frustrating thing in chess when i first
learned the game i remember all of my
opponents they would just copy every
single move i played and somehow i
didn't know how to punish them and that
is happening now it's quite rare i must
say but uh okay it's also rare to see
two dings two dings are better than one
but there we go
and actually the position is about to
repeat itself i hope we're not gonna see
a quick draw at this early stage magnus
now deciding whether to put his knight
in the center of the board or whether to
try a different strategy so right now
okay this is the second time we've seen
this position
ding last time brought the white knight
out the black knight retreated
okay will we see white retreat his
knight
the game's over guys anti-climax it's a
quick draw i'm surprised these two
playing a quick draw it is a little bit
surprising especially when you take into
account the standings yeah i mean
they're the
round the danger zone when it comes to
the quality